the president is not going to be asking
europe to do things that they simply
cannot do
where we are in a position to do them
we're going to take our actions other
countries will do the same we completely
understand that the united states is in
a different position and we are not
making judgments about any country who
have to get their source of fuel from
anywhere if they can avoid getting it
from vladimir putin the world cannot
rely on
america and other western allies to
boost supply and send every molecule of
gas that isn't going to plug the gap for
every country that needs it and so we do
have a situation where for example boris
johnson
prime minister of the uk is going to
saudi arabia to ask for more oil a
country with a tremendously concerning
human rights record what is america's
position on that well we understand the
importance of increasing global supply
of oil so the question is really how do
we get supply up somewhere and that's
why we're asking our producers to
increase supply i know other countries
are doing the same
that is ultimately a short-term solution
the medium and long-term solution is
switching
switching our fuel system so that we are
relying not on
russia not on saudi arabia but we're
relying on ourselves that we have energy
independence and that energy
independence is coming from sources that
cannot be controlled by dictators no
country has been held hostage to access
to the sun or to access to wind so
that's why we have to accelerate to
clean even if in the short term we have
to face some you know unpleasant choices
is there a contradiction perhaps in
you calling for
a huge increase in fossil fuel supply
while at the same time also calling for
massive investment in
renewables can you see how that might be
sending mixed messages totally but we
can walk and chew gum at the same time
we can increase supply for the immediate
need and we can accelerate our move to
clean energy and in fact the former only
gives fuel to the latter that we must we
must accelerate so that we are not uh
held hostage to vladimir putin will the
ukraine crisis
impact the world's ability to limit
global warming energy security
and the movement to clean energy are
inextricably linked
and i think the ukraine crisis has
brought this to a head
and ensures that the world will be
completely focused on being secure
energy independent each nation and
that's why i think the ukraine crisis
yes while in the short term may cause a
scramble for immediate solutions to fuel
but in the medium and long term it will
accelerate our movement to clean